for years now telltale Games's
masterfully exploited our fear of making
the wrong decision the games tell you
that every action you take has a
consequence then light a fuse and watch
as he stumble over impossible decisions
but when you're Batman the world's most
cool calm and collected detective tells
emotional manipulation shouldn't be as
effective decision paralysis holds no
power over the Dark Knight therein lies
the challenge how do you make a
character known for being decisive and
infallible falter telltale solution is
to shift the focus away from Batman and
dig into Bruce Wayne instead a decision
that proves to be the right one Bruce
tell me whatever you want you don't have
to do this
episode 1 realm of shadows
effectively makes the man more important
than the hero and provides a strong star
to the series with Harvey Dent running
for mayor and Bruce as his most vocal
backer Gotham City's on the verge of
changing for the better together they
threaten the status quo where corrupt
city officials are in the pocket of
criminals the citizens of Gotham may not
be sold on then but they hold the Wayne
reputation and word in high regard this
dynamic is what telltale plays with to
create tension many of the choices in
episode 1 on matters of life and death
but they still weigh heavy you're forced
to choose between what you personally
think is right what you think Bruce
Wayne would do and what you believe will
help Harvey's campaign do you shake
carmine Falcone his hand to secure
support potentially tarnishing your own
reputation or do you turn them away
knowing that these same hands are
drowning Gotham in crime the nagging
knowledge that choices and actions have
profound consequences pull you in
different directions and make you
second-guess the situations may be
understated but they're full of drama
chalk this for me be a pal I can get
Harvey the mayor's seat or I can pull it
out from under
whatever happened to being a gracious
host for the most part the cast of
characters are familiar alfred is
keeping Bruce Wayne from being consumed
by his crusade
Harvey Dent is the hand reaching into
the darkness to pull Gotham out and
Selena Kyle is a selfish thief with a
little good in her but there are
elements of them that have been
reimagined in subtle ways for some it's
their personalities for others it's
their relationships one noble character
is completely reinvented and will play a
pivotal role in the story but it's
ominously unclear how Bruce meanwhile is
in the early stages of being Batman and
more emotionally unsettled this means
dialogue responses can be used to create
the type of Bruce you want you can be
aloof self-centered optimistic or
brooding but since tell tells excellent
rang has a way of making it difficult to
roleplay as a single type you're more
likely to get a mixture of all of them
the emotional variety paints a Bruce
that hasn't hard India instead he feels
human and genuine and this extends into
his crime-fighting alter-ego Falcone
leaving his Rose here this is a message
dead cops stolen chemicals he's making a
big move this may be a Bruce Wayne story
but when the going gets tough the tough
put on a Batman suit telltale has built
Batman's game player on conducting
investigations and solving puzzles and
it's done it to great effect players can
interact with elements of their
surrounding and collect evidence to
piece together the events of a crime you
physically walk between points of
interest and draw a holographic line
connecting the relevant evidence
together Batman's a bit of a slow Walker
by recreation of the events courtesy of
the cowls holographic interface is a
fitting reward for solving the conundrum
another set piece involves firing
through a room full of thugs by
inspecting them and then linking them to
nearby objects just like with connecting
pieces of evidence once again the cowls
holographic interface runs a simulation
so you can choose whether you prefer to
slam a guard into a concrete pillar or
throw a priceless art piece at his head
once an attack plan is formulated
there's the execution phase and this
works like QuickTime event sequences in
other telltale games although telltale
has honed in on Batman's methodical
preparation and tactical powers for
combat this comes at the cost of feeling
his raw power and ferociousness
somewhere between pressing a button and
watching Batman tear through
goons the energy dissipates that
disconnect deepens when you stop
pressing bonds all together and notice
that Batman continues to lay waste to
his enemies with little to no change in
his performance the only time you're
punished for missing your cues is if
it's the final blow which needs to learn
to progress on to the next scene
otherwise you're just losing out on
filling a meet are used for a special
cinematic attack while not as distinct
as the neon noir of the wolf among us
Telltale's Batman has a great visual
identity in keeping with the property
thick marker like lions accentuate finer
details in characters and ambient
lighting brings some vibrancy to the
game a wall of screen fills the Batcave
of a futuristic blue hue and in the
Wayne Manor a roaring fire brings warmth
to the dark corners of the living room
moon light coats Batman's suit cutting
that iconic silhouette into the Gotham
sky and the dimmed street lamps create
an air of danger on the seedy streets
Batman's alpha is particularly cool with
the stubby ears of Frank Miller's
incarnation paying or March to his
legacy and Greg Capullo streamlined
biker suit style representing the more
modern design his glowing white eyes
give him an imposing presence making his
victims look like deer caught in the
headlights
see where you walk
while many fixate on breaking the Batman
telltale wants to bring down Bruce Wayne
and it demonstrates an understanding
that people and relationships are key to
this episode one begins the process of
unraveling him and sets a stage to lay
him bare impressively by sticking to his
strengths telltale also delivers on the
experience of being Batman realm of
Shadows establishes a compelling Bruce
Wayne narrative and is a worthy start to
the series but excited to see what
happens